be comfortable
you believing me is all I need
welcome to law and Flash order this is
gonna be my episode 10 video there were
so many Easter eggs they're obviously
trying to stick very close to the trial
of the flash comic book arc which was
sort of the last big Barry Allen arc
from the comics so let's do top 10 WTF
and comic book Easter eggs as we go
along and there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter just be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video so number 10
really important teaser for what's to
come later iris is the person who has
the idea that Barry said something
during the trial that he said when he
came out the gibberish she was speaking
meaning that they're gonna go back and
start really analyzing that very very
important because Wally was in the
speedforce Barry saw the future so it's
the key to defeating the thinker so they
have it around them they just don't know
what it is because they haven't decoded
it yet there's no context for it
so like this house is bitchin we're
gonna need more diapers doesn't sound
like anything to them even though we as
the audience have already connected a
lot of those dots but another really
good example of foreshadowing is the
beginning of the trial when they read
Barry's full name Bartholomew Henry
Allen and then later at the end of the
episode he sees the wall and finds out
that Henry Allen his father was in the
cell that they just stuck him in so it's
a nice bookend for the episode and then
obviously you know number 9 Joe starts
going on the warpath
trying to clear Barry using all the
creeper skills that elongated man picked
up as a private detective so they go
full Jessica Jones trying to catch the
thinker's wife boning with the new
version of the thinker even though it
totally doesn't work the whole idea
there is is that he failed Barry's
father like if you saw the clip that I
posted from the first episode in my last
video how he was adamant that Barry's
father really did kill his mother and
didn't believe Barry about the man in
yellow
turns out all Barry's conspiracy
theories were right he's not gonna be
wrong again I'm not gonna fail Barry the
way I failed his father so it's this
nice book in for the beginning of the
series and what was happening during
season 1 with his father being falsely
accused of murder
taking that foreshadowing a step further
they also imply in future episode
descriptions the beer is gonna run into
someone with a special connection to
Henry Allen so they just want to remind
you of things in this episode so they
foreshadow the gibberish he was speaking
because that's going to come back around
there's a brand new ability that he
manifest
that'll be really important in a later
episode so there is a lot of
foreshadowing for all kinds of different
plot points some of them have to do with
the trial which is a smaller arc some of
them are gonna be paid off later this
season with the big battle with the
thinker but number 8 the actual trial of
the flash now this was actually a really
big comic book arc because it covers
everything from Barry killing the
reverse-flash to save his fiancee Fiona
Webb in eventually they ended that comic
book run with him then going on to
crisis on Infinite Earths they cancelled
the flash comic book and when it came
back it was the wally west era of the
comics because barry died or supposedly
died during crisis but if you want to
read along in the comics is it's a
really long run it goes from issue
number 323 all the way to 350 so there's
a lot of stuff that happens between the
actual trial but number 7 mark Balley
the person who is prosecuting him you
may recognize as Christopher chance the
human target from the human target TV
show a couple of years ago
he's a DC Comics character that arrow
repurposed last season so if you are a
big comic book fan I don't think that
they're sticking exactly to the flash
trial from the comics because there were
a lot of really crazy comic book level
twists things that would just seem
ridiculous if they did him during the TV
show so like people were pretending to
be other people I don't think they're
gonna take it that far like abracadabra
was a big part of the arc I don't think
that he's going to be part of the trial
of the flash I think it's gonna last for
a couple episodes tops then they'll
resolve that Barry will find his way out
and they'll move into more of a legit
battle with the thinker in the back half
of the season but for the next couple of
episodes
obviously they intend to do an arc with
Barry inside iron Heights
so number six they do have the meta of
the week plot he's one of the new busts
metas his name is fallout he is a comic
book character he basically just gives
off radiation he's like a walking
nuclear bomb so the crazy thing here
talk about foreshadowing is that they
solved the problem by venting him into
another earth that Harrison wells says
is dead earth 15 it's a dead earth I
hope it's dead otherwise the people just
ate a tonne of radiation but they might
choose to bring that back is the tip-off
for a crossover if they like vent some
trash into another universe and it
causes problems for the
in that universe like how dare you dump
all your garbage here without thinking
about us so just remember that there are
consequences to their actions and like
sometimes even when they're trying to
help people or go about their daily
lives they hurt people that was sort of
the metaphor of the Fallout character
like he was just going to the bank
trying to get money so that he could go
about his daily life he wasn't trying to
hurt people so like Barry isn't trying
to hurt people but through his own
actions without intending it there is
collateral damage
to being a hero so just remember that
idea collateral damage could always
cause some problems for Team flash down
the road but this is obviously more
about the thinker right now in the bus
metas number five the thinker's wife
reminds iris that there are problems
that are bigger in the world that
they're trying to solve the whole reason
for her throwing team flash under the
bus trying to get Barry out of the way
is so that the thinker can enact his
plan to enlighten the world the thinker
is so dead set on saving the world that
it'll be fascinating to find out what
his actual plan is we haven't gotten any
clues for that yet only that the 12
metas working together will help him
enact that plan they reminded us in the
episode that they're not just
distractions for Team flash because
Barry's like why are you distracting us
and he's like oh no there's a much
bigger plan than that but number four
really cool Barry manifests a new
ability so that iris can't give him up
as the flash now there's this comic book
cover here this is very clearly what
they're aping like barry being unmasked
in his trial to try and clear a path to
his defense
this person is married to the thinker
that's the body that you found but he
secretly transferred his consciousness
you can't go to that without explaining
how Barry is involved with these people
and then you have to explain how he's
the flash so Barry's like we're not
doing that we're not gonna do any of
that stuff please just be quiet iris but
the cool thing is is that he didn't know
that he could bring her into SuperSpeed
with him so like I said that's more
foreshadowing for him using that ability
later this season in a really cool way
like anytime there's a really cool new
ability like throwing lightning at the
beginning of season 2 it always comes
back around several episodes down the
line like with the flash getting
lightning thrown back at him but number
three was them trying to get killer
frost to manifest that was actually
pretty funny then just yelling
katelyn she's like I can't do it on
command I don't know how to do that yet
they'll find an easier way for her to go
full-blown killer Frost's on a dime
eventually but you do kind of sense that
she's not totally aware of what's going
on is this business pleasure what's
going on here up looks like business so
you guys can let me know how you feel
about this version of killer frost where
she's kind of helping the team she's
kind of friends like during episode 9
when they make the joke about the baking
powder like team flash has been hanging
out with killer frost and Caitlin
doesn't know it and it bums her out
because they're like killer frost is way
cooler to hang out within you she's way
more fun but really cool Easter Egg
number two when they're sentencing him
with like when he's going into booking
at the beginning of the episode the
number on that slate there is the date
that they published the trial of the
flash comic book in my number one is
obviously berry going into the prison
cell at iron Heights and realizing that
it was his father cell so you cry a
little bit but it's very meaningful and
it's a good book in for what happened
during season 1 I'm an innocent man I
didn't do this so again just remember
that the key to defeating the thinker
this season is in the gibberish and now
they know to start analyzing that but
obviously it didn't happen during this
episode so that'll probably come back
either next week or the week after that
but let me know in the comments which a
favorite thing from the episode and what
are you looking forward to during the
iron Heights run like while Barry's
inside prison clearly it looks like
there's some sort of crazy prison fight
in next week's episode but just remember
that as the flash and as Barry Allen CSI
he helped put a lot of those criminals
in prison and now he's in there with
them but I will do a trailer video for
next week's episode in a black lightning
episode one video next so I'll try to
get those up Wednesday morning
congratulations to the latest flash ring
giveaway winner Joe show please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video I'll just announce the winner when
I post my DC videos tomorrow so click
here for my flash Legion of super-heroes
videos and you can click here for that
Deadpool Family Guy episode thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight